this video is made possible by
brilliance you'll learn more about
brilliant later in today's video but if
you'd like to learn more around them
right now get a brilliant dog /by
graphics you'll also find a link in the
description below Socrates is considered
the father of Western philosophy he was
a man who questioned everything and
everyone with no regard for how his
opinions would be received he imposed
his views with a dogmatic superiority
thus eventually sealed his fate still
his great legacy to the world was the
method of questioning to arrive at the
truth which is known as the Socratic
method
today on biographic s-- we're going to
discover the man who was Socrates of all
the great figures of antiquity none are
as frustrating for the historian as
Socrates the man never wrote down
anything that has survived so the only
records of his life come from secondary
sources the two main ones are from Plato
his devoted students and Xenophon they
contemporary of Plato these writings
mainly consist of records of
conversations that often included
Socrates himself discerning the facts of
his life from such writings is a bit of
a challenge
in fact this lack of solid biographical
information is actually known as the
Socratic problem Socrates was either
born in 469 or 470 BCE in a Greek
village located a 20 minute walk away
from Athens his father sovereign discus
was a sculptor while his mother Feiner
ata worked as a midwife sovereign discus
wanted his son to take on the craft of a
sculptor so during his youth he was
apprenticed to his father he apparently
became an accomplished sculptor with
tradition having it that he worked on a
well-known statue entitled the three
muses in their habits which was
displayed at the Acropolis as a young
man socrates devoured the writings of
the Greek philosopher and eggs a gross
it is believed that he may have actually
studied under this master but this
cannot be determined with certainty the
basic teachings all of Alexander s were
that all things have always existed but
in their original form we're in tiny
fragments of their current form in
Athens the Agora or public square was
the central meeting place for men who
would discuss politics art and
philosophy
as he was Philly Youth Socrates was not
able to attend the Agora instead he
spent much of his free time in the
workshops of the city's merchants where
he would engage them in philosophical
questioning after some time working as a
sculptor Socrates went off to study
under the philosophical master arc Elias
he studied mathematics and astronomy and
became familiar with the work of earlier
philosophers according to a third
century biographer by the name of
Diogenes laetus
oculus embarks upon a homosexual
relationship with Socrates a practice
which was widespread in ancient Greece
at the time that Socrates began showing
an interest in philosophy the discipline
was about a hundred years old the ideas
that were being thrown around were
largely theoretical barring little
practical application Socrates soon came
to the realization there the things that
he was learning they didn't really have
any benefit to society he was far more
interested in addressing the problems of
everyday life despite his curiosity to
understand the world he was not a
scientific thinker rather than
questioning the world to understand how
it worked he believed that we would be
better off questioning ourselves in
order to understand how we work he
adopted the quote which has often been
wrongly attributed to him and that's
know thyself
[Music]
with the outbreak of the Peloponnesian
War in 431 BCE Socrates was recruited as
a hoplite the equivalent of a private
third class he immediately stood out
among his fellow conscripts even though
there is much discrepancy about the
details of his life there is one thing
about Socrates upon which there is
universal agreement and that's that he
was ugly
he had a snub nose and his hair was long
and unkempt he also showed no interest
in personal grooming and also rarely
bathed we know about Socrates military
service from the writings of Plato in
Plato's work apology he tells us that
his master fought in the battles of
Amphipolis Delia and Potter Dyer another
chronicler Alcibiades specifically
mentioned Socrates heroic actions in the
battle of Delian stating that the
philosopher saved his life during the
fighting having completed his military
service in 406 BCE Socrates was
appointed as a member of the bull which
was a 500 member council which ran the
daily affairs of Athens
Xena form tells us that he was the
overseer of a debate that was held to
determine the fates of a number of
military commanders who had abandoned
their wounded in battle in order to
pursue the Spartans the public were
clamoring for the men's be put to death
but Socrates he blocked the vote and he
spared the men's lives
[Laughter]
with the end of the Peloponnesian War in
404 BC there was a period of upheaval in
Athens that resulted in the coming to
power of a group known as the thirty
tyrants these men instituted a period of
Terror marked by bloodshed and
confiscation of property after eight
months the rebel regime fell and was
replaced with the Democratic Greek
governments but that hardly meant that
life was going to get better for
Socrates in fact it was about to get a
whole lot worse Socrates was an opponent
of democracy he believed that the people
as a whole were incapable of self-rule
they needed a wise Shepherd to guide
them in their lives
he further claims that the ordinary
citizen did not possess any innate a
virtue that would given them the ability
to speak on behalf of others virtue he
maintained was something that is
attained only by knowledge and that
knowledge was beyond the scope of the
everyday person these ideas they were
sharply at odds with those of the
Athenian society in which Socrates lived
the people cherished the enlightened
right of every citizen having a voice in
the assembly as a result the ideas of
Socrates were viewed with suspicion if
not outright hostility things weren't
helped by there are the condescending
and arrogance manner in which he
expressed his views he was dismissive of
those who held views contrary to his own
this frequently led to violent reactions
Diogenes records that men set upon him
with their fists or tore his hair out
faced with this Socrates bought all this
ill-usage patiently a fascinating
contemporary view of Socrates is
provided by the Athenian comic
playwright Aristophanes in 423 BC he
wrote a play called of the clouds in
that play is a character who is clearly
based on Socrates this character the
headmaster of a thinker II is presented
as a comic buffoon who stalks the
streets barefoot looking down his nose
at the ignorant masses and for rolling
his eyes at the unintelligible guttural
murmurings that he hears Socrates was
apparently friendly with Aristophanes
and held no grudge against such
portrayals in fact Plutarch quotes him
is saying the following when they break
a jest upon me in the theatre I feel as
if I were at a big party of good friends
it appears then that around the four 20s
Socrates was seen by most people as a
call audible who was slightly annoying
but generally harmless but well that
view it was about to change the
democracy that athenians so cherished it
was challenged on two occasions during
Socrates later years during a four-month
periods in 411 - 410 BCE Athenian
democracy it was overthrown then in 404
BCE the thirty tyrants usurped a
democracy assuring in eight months of
chaos
both of these interactions were led by
former students of Socrates Alcibiades
and Critias relatives of Plato the first
of these interactions turns public
opinion against Socrates as the brains
behind the coup with the bloodshed
caused by the seconds over three people
began so you indirectly blame the
philosopher for the carnage with the
coming to power of the thirty tyrants
the former leaders of the democracy fled
to the mountains it was there that they
plans their resistance the elders of the
new totalitarian government did not
directly involve Socrates in the
carrying out of their wicked act except
on one single occasion they summoned him
along with four other men and ordered
them to go to Salamis and apprehends a
learned man of influence by the name of
Leon and then bring him back to Athens
to be executed this man was an
upstanding honest citizen who had done
nothing deserving of condemnation let
alone death Socrates refused to do this
dirty work stating that he would never
perform an act that compromised his
integrity however he didn't do anything
to warn Leon of the impending danger as
a result the other four men went ahead
and apprehended Leon and he was
summarily put to death this failure to
proactively warn Leon it would come back
to Horn Socrates at his upcoming trial
rather than being viewed as the local
eccentric Socrates was now being seen by
many as a dangerous spreader of radical
ideas that were leading others to the
most vile excesses in 403 BCE the rule
of the thirty tyrants was over and the
former democratic governments had been
restored a General Assembly had been
enacted which meant that no one
including Socrates could be brought up
on charges of their actions during the
eight months of tyranny now just before
we get into the downfall of Socrates I
do want to briefly talk about today's
sponsor brilliant and I know as always
these ads in the middle less than
awesome but brilliant are fantastic for
sponsoring this sort of longer content
because it allows us to share these
stories of some of the world's greatest
historical think
brilliant or a science learning platform
that allow you to learn through active
learning which sums up is basically the
opposite of that feeling of reading a
bunch of complex information about some
principle and just having it going
completely over your head and brilliant
don't just deal with the basics although
they do cover that as well they go all
the way through to very complex things
like advanced statistics brilliant have
a relatively new feature it's called
daily problems and it's five minutes a
day that you can use to exercise your
brain and learn something new each
problem provides you the context and
framework you need to tackle it that
means you can learn concepts by applying
them that's that active learning this
sort of short daily practice can lead
you from curiosity to mastery in far
less time than you might think I've been
using brilliant it's excellent you
should go try it out it just even if
it's just to see how quickly you can
understand those complex subjects you
can support this show by going to
brilliant dog /by graphics and now let's
get on with our exploration of socrates
is life Socrates was finally arrested in
399 BCE by then the state has out of 4
years since the end of the last revolt
to come up with some charges against him
during that period Socrates appeared to
be undeterred by the return to favor of
democracy and the antipathy towards
those who espouse two views in
opposition to it
he continued to deride democracy and
champion rule by a strong leader when
there was another attempted overthrow in
401 the state at had enough of his
revolutionising of the impressionable
youth it was now just a matter of time
before he was brought to account
Athenian law allowed for any citizen to
bring criminal proceedings against
another man a man named mellitus brought
an oral summons against Socrates the
summons required him to appear before
illegal magistrates who faced charges of
impiety and corrupting the youth the
magistrate heard out the applicants and
determines that the were grounds for a
preliminary hearing at that hearing the
charges were read out and Socrates was
given the opportunity to answer them a
documents containing the charges was
drawn up along with the requested
penalty it read Socrates is guilty of
refusing to recognize the gods
recognized by the state and introducing
new divinities is also guilty of
corrupting the youth the penalty
demanded
death the actual trial took place of a
period of nine hours in the Agora in the
center of Athens the jury was made up of
five hundred citizens drawn by lot the
large number was standard in ancient
trials and seemed to have been mainly to
prevent bribery from swaying the outcome
of cases after the reading over the
charges the three main accusers of
Socrates were given three hours to
present that case there is no surviving
record of their testimony but we do know
that the main accuser was not mellitus
but a certain Anytus who is also a
politician who harbored ongoing
resentments against Socrates it is
believed that the son of anita's was a
student with whom Socrates that had a
homosexual relationship something which
greatly upset the father it is likely
that the main thrust of the accusations
was that Socrates was leading young
people down a dangerous political path
with his anti-democratic teachings
however in Plato's apology in which he
provides an account of Socrates his
defense considerable weight is given to
his defense of the charge of impiety
piety in those days involved not only
respect for the Greek gods but also for
the dead and for one's ancestors if
there was even one in pious person in
the city it was a serious matter as that
once incursions might bring the wrath of
the gods upon the entire city even
though the Athenians have no written
scriptural code and no priesthood there
was a significant number of rituals
observances and offerings that were
required it is highly likely that
socrates neglected to observe the
rituals of the gods that would have been
expected of him furthermore he would
have argued that the generally accepted
view of worship is being based on
rituals was wrong according to Xena faun
Socrates had the ability to communicate
directly with the gods this would have
infuriated those in attendance at his
trial including the 500 jurors it is
difficult for us to know just what if
any religious beliefs
Socrates actually held throughout his
dialogues Plato has him referring to
both one gods and also to plural gods it
has also been suggested that he viewed
the word God is referring to the
philosophical idea of goodness a
critical part of the accusations against
him had to do with his close association
with the leaders of the thirty tyrants
rebellion specifically his ties to the
leader of the revolt prettiest in his
defense socrates brought up the time
when he was ordered to go into Rath lien
of Salamis he
claims that his refusal to do so was a
clear indication that he was not in
cahoots with the rebels and was indeed a
loyal citizen of Athens but his accuser
countered that a loyal citizen would
have done more than simply refrain from
the bad action he would have warned the
innocent man and was therefore saved his
life
socrates spoke in his own defense for
three full hours of the dozens of
versions of it that were made only two
have survived down to our time those of
Plato and Xenophon the versions agree
that the master was defiant in his tone
almost as if he were inviting an adverse
judgment as part of his defense socrates
told the jurors that he was a hero he
recalled his exemplary military service
he then extended the thought with an
analogy telling them that he had fought
for decades to save the souls of young
Athenians if teaching virtue made him
guilty of corruption he said then that
he was guilty as charged
he then assured his listeners with the
following men of Athens I honor and love
you but I shall obey God rather than you
and when I have life and strength
I shall never cease from the practice
and teaching of philosophy in the face
of the charge that he was a Corrupter of
the youth of Athens Socrates stated that
he never claimed to be a teacher he was
merely a man who happened to spend time
strolling around the city if he was
asked a question he would answer it to
the best of his ability then pointing to
Plato and others of his followers in the
crowd he pointed out that none of them
had ever laid an accusation against him
those of his former students who had
done bad he said did so because they
corrupted the things that he had set as
the marathon speech crew to a close it
was obvious to everyone listening that
Socrates had no intention of stopping
doing whatever it was that the people
objected to the only way to stop him we
support him to death contrary to normal
practice in such proceedings he made no
please for any mercy after nine hours of
proceedings the jury of 500 were tasked
with making their decision unlike today
the jury did not retire to discuss their
thoughts they simply voted by placing a
disk in one of two urns labeled guilty
or not guilty with the urn that held the
most votes determining the outcome when
they had completed this task there were
280 discs in the guilty urn and 220 in
the not guilty one but the jury's job it
was not yet over they had to determine
the penalty the accusers of
these rows and put forward their case
that the condemned umpires corruptor of
the youth of Athens must be put to death
Socrates himself was then invited to put
forward a case for leniency this was his
opportunity to win some favor with the
jury
perhaps by suggesting that he be sent
into exile but true to his nature he
refused to step down from his position
of superior integration he should he
suggested to be rewarded rather than
condemned for his actions the court
officials they were not impressed and he
was told to give a more realistic
alternative penalty
Socrates then offered that he could be
subjected to a modest fine faced with
these two extremes of punishments the
jurors they chose death with the trial
now over Socrates was taken to an
adjoining prison cell according to the
records of his final days penned by
Plato Socrates was given the opportunity
to escape when he was visited in his
cell by his wealthy friend Crito this
man had already laid plans to smuggle
Socrates out of Athens
however the condemned man showed no
interest in escaping his fate the
conversation between the two men as
Crito attempted to persuade socrates to
escape and the great philosophers
responses present an important aspect of
Socrates as moral code Crito afford
three points as to why Socrates should
escape from his death sentence firstly
the death would be a bad reflection on
the followers of Socrates's people would
think that they'd abandoned him secondly
all finances involved in the escape were
covered and furthermore a comfortable
life in exile had been arranged finally
his death would leave his sons without a
father
in response socrates countered that a
man should not worry about public
opinion but only be guided by wisdom the
only real question to consider in the
situation was whether or not it was just
for Socrates to escape his condemnation
to death he then spoke of the laws of
Athens stating that to break one of
those laws meant breaking them all to go
against the laws of Athens would be like
a child rebelling against a parent he
argued if he dared to go against the
laws of the city he asserted he would
receive a harsh judgment in the
underworld as a result socrates refused
the offer of escape his fate it was now
sealed
Plato chronicled his death in his work
Phaedo in it he gives an eyewitness
account from the viewpoint of the
fictional character of fado
according to the accounts and
came into the cell carrying cup of
poisoned hemlock Socrates turned to him
and said now good sir you understand
these things tell me what I must do the
man replied just drink it and walk
around until your legs begin to feel
heavy then lie down
it will soon act the cup was then
offered to Socrates he took it happily
and asked if it was permissible for him
to offer a pledge before drinking it
permission was granted and he offered
the following prayer we can and must
pray to the gods that our sojourn on
earth will continue happy beyond the
grave this is my prayer and may it come
to pass at this he drank the poison
without hesitation those of his friends
who were in the cell with him gave way
to tears prompting Socrates to declare
you are strange fellows what is wrong
with you I send the women away for this
very purpose to stop their creating such
a scene I have heard that one should die
in silence so please keep quiet and to
keep control of yourselves for the next
few minutes he walked around the room
then when his legs became heavy he laid
down on his bed with a covering over his
face slowly he lost feeling first in his
legs then moving up his body his last
words directed Crito were Crito we owe a
cock to escape yes do pay us don't
forget this seems a rather strange
request but it makes sense when we
realized that his creepiest was the god
of good health the sacrifice of a cock
was a normal offering her thanks for
recovery from illness
Socrates believed that he was cured of
the disease of life and was as a result
not frightened of death creature then
asked him if there was anything else he
wanted to say but there was no reply the
poison had reached his heart and the
life of Socrates was drained away Plato
continued his account with these words
this was the end of our friends the best
wisest and most upright man of any that
I have ever known so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do give us a thumbs up below and
don't forget to subscribe we've got
brand new videos like this several times
a week so hit that subscribe button to
find out about all of those also feeling
there's something else watch right now
why not check out my other channel today
I found out you'll find a link to that
in the description below and as always
thank you for watching
you
[Music]